so you obviously uh I just watched your
uh your interview with Gillian Walla
which I thought was super dope because I
really thought just from like a
perspective of like any young man that's
living life right now there's so much to
take from your story
and
um I think that like when we think about
incarceration and
being at your absolute worst in life I
think that I'm sure
being in a jail cell not knowing how
long you're going to be locked up
I know you said you ended up not doing
the whole 10 you did five
um but mentally to be able to like
bounce back
after you get released and like kind of
not let up if anything level up like
that takes a lot of mental fortitude man
oh definitely should I still battle with
it today but I still I'm still
transitioning you know what I'm saying
it's still a whole lot of [ __ ] that I
don't know it's still a whole lot of
[ __ ] like I learned something new every
day
yeah I might not even speak on her but I
was like damn I like to see a certain
[ __ ] that I battle with like damn I
can't believe it should go like this but
I gotta do it like especially with this
internet [ __ ] especially with the
industry you know what I'm saying like
we you know what I'm saying just rubbing
elbows with like the fake love you know
I'm saying like I grew up on principles
and more so you know like the fake love
like this [ __ ] get under your skin but
you gotta deal with it
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah deal
with it it's like the industry like
friendships and then there's like the
real friendships and it's like trying to
figure out how to like maneuver and play
the game in in a way where you don't
take
the industry [ __ ] personal and you don't
take offense to it you just kind of know
what it is and at the same time be aware
of like what's actually happening you
know what I'm saying right right you
said like uh the baby uh somebody who
reached out to you while you were locked
up showed you love Kevin Gates those
were two of the first people who you
tapped in with when you got it baby like
I just heard baby was riding in my music
but Gage actually reached out like case
was reaching out like on like two or
three different occasions like you know
what I'm saying like but like when I got
around guys I could feel his generosity
I could feel like where he come from the
struggle the pain and [ __ ] like so so
[ __ ] like that like they gonna Embrace
this [ __ ] some people can just feel this
[ __ ] through lyrics like yeah you could
tell when a [ __ ] actually done
something with a [ __ ] ain't you
know what I'm saying like or they just
they they putting they didn't product
did something but they putting extra
[ __ ] on it right you know what I'm
saying like so you know you can you know
I'm saying if you come from that [ __ ]
you're gonna be able to you yeah Gates
is also somebody who's also kind of been
into similar situations where he was
incarcerated and I think that you know